-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
I'm in a stranger's apartment.
Let's get to the news.
During a speech yesterday
in Atlanta,
President Biden endorsed
changing the Senate filibuster
in order to pass federal
voting rights legislation
and said, "I'm tired
of being quiet."
Quiet?
When did we ever say
we wanted a quiet president?
Oh, right. Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we may have
put it out there.
During a hearing yesterday,
Republican Senator Richard Burr
criticized the
Biden Administration's
Coronavirus pandemic messaging
and said that the American
people are "confused."
Said Biden, "It's simple.
Just wear a mask indoors.
Unless you're indoors,
and then you can
safely make outdoors indoors
so long as your booster stays
six feet away
from sheltering in place."
Come on, Jack!
A new op-ed
in "The Wall Street Journal"
suggests that Hillary Clinton
could be the best
Democratic nominee for the 2024
presidential election,
because all voters
really want right now
is someone who admits it
when they lose.
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
has subpoenaed two advisers
to Donald Trump Jr.
to try to find out
what exactly it is that they do.
Former President Trump
reportedly hung up
on NPR journalist
Steve Inskeep yesterday
just 9 minutes
into a 15-minute interview.
Though, to be fair, who among us
hasn't tapped out 9 minutes
into a 15-minute NPR segment?
I say that as a fan.
Been there.
Former Democratic presidential
hopefuls Andrew Yang
and Marianne Williamson
had dinner on Monday
in New York City.
"Please, no photos,"
said the restaurant.
Kellogg's recently released
a Valentine's Day-themed
Froot Loops cereal that
includes heart-shaped pieces.
But if that's
what she wants this year,
she's too young for you, dude!
Does it look like
I'm looking at him?
Listen, you guys know,
in reality,
I'm just looking at a wall.
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos
turned 58 years old today.
If you want to wish him a happy
birthday, just say it out loud.
I'm sure one of your devices
will get the message to him.
Pope Francis visited
a record shop in Rome yesterday
and left with a CD.
And I gotta say,
I didn't even realize
the Popemobile had visors.
Two of our writers
wrote that joke.
Which is weird,
because all of our writers
are 22 or younger.
And, finally... [ Laughs ]
And finally, the Girl Scouts
have partnered with
the delivery platform DoorDash
to allow local troops
to sell cookies through the app.
Meanwhile, at the Boy Scouts?
Still trying to make a fire
with sticks.
They develop slower.
It's just a boy/girl thing.
You guys, that was
the monologue.